bonjour madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour monsieur merci d'être fidèle à
notre rendez vous de ce dimanche 19
septembre
désormais si vous le voulez bien chaque
dimanche à cette même heure
nous nous retrouverons pour jouer
ensemble à notre nouveau jeu
le mot le plus long et puisque vous nous
fait l'amitié de nous recevoir chez vous
je vais vous demander de vous installer
le plus confortablement possible pas
trop loin de votre récepteur de
télévision de façon à ce que nous
puissions être très près les uns des
autres et que vous puissiez jouer avec
nous car ne l'oubliez pas ce jeu a été
fait pour que vous amis téléspectateurs
vous puissiez jouer avec nous exactement
dans les mêmes conditions que nos
concurrents en studio rassurez-vous la
règle de notre jeu est extrêmement
simple
je pense qu'il n'est pas utile que je
vous donne au départ de très longues
explications il suffit que vous ne
regardiez joué pendant quelques minutes
et vous aurez tout de suite compris et
vous rentrerez dans le jeu avec nous il
faut beau temps que je vous présente les
différents éléments de ce jeu tout
d'abord nous aurons deux concurrents
deux concurrents qui vont jouer l'un
contre l'autre et qui vont s'affronter
sur ce parcours
ce parcours que vous voyez qui comporte
18 case 9 blanche et 9 noir vous saurez
tout à l'heure pour quoi bien entendu le
vainqueur sera celui qui aura franchi à
la fin de la partie c'est à dire à la
fin de l'émission le plus grand nombre
de cases
il y a bien entendu d'autres précisions
que je vous donnerai en cours de jeu
comment l'as vence sur le parcours
va-t-elle s'effectuer bien dans le moule
plus long nous avons remplacé le des
traditionnels des jeux de société
parages
deux lettres chaque concurrent va
disposer de cette lettre à l'aide
desquels il devra composer un mot s'il
fait un mot de trois lettres
il avancera de trois cases s'il fait un
mot de quatre lettres il avancera de
4,15
mais si un candidat par exemple fait un
mot de quatre lettres mais que son
adversaire fait lui un mot de cinq
lettres
c'est ce dernier qui avancera puisqu'il
aura fait le mot le plus long
il ya d'autres précisions que je vous
donnerai tout à l'heure en cours de
partie pour ne pas vous embrouiller
mais nos candidats nos concurrents les
connaissent déjà
j'ai d'ailleurs vous les présenter ses
concurrents bonjour messieurs c'est très
gentil d'être venu essuyé les plâtres en
quelque sorte de notre émission j'espère
que ça nous portera chance et à vous
aussi monsieur quel est votre nom pierre
armes
monsieur armand votre profession chef de
publicité oui et vous habitez colombes
cole environ reste paris et vous
monsieur jean-pierre lichtenberg
l'étudiant en médecine j'habite à paris
paris donc c'est presque un pari contre
tu as bon et bien et je dois encore vous
présenter quelques uns mais là c'est une
surprise
eh bien oui vous le reconnaissez c'est
monsieur pichon monsieur pichon qui fut
l'un des héros de l'homme du 20e siècle
et ce soir aujourd'hui monsieur pichon
n'est pas avec nous en qualité de
candidat non armand jammot lui a demandé
de venir m'aider en quelque sorte à
animer cette émission est de remplir le
rôle très important d'arbitré
dictionnaire puisque vous le savez
monsieur pichon et professeurs ou sur
l'histoire je crois monsieur michaud rue
donc personne autre que jean était mieux
qualifiés pour trancher les débats en
cas de litige sur un mot et d'ailleurs
il va vous expliquer beaucoup mieux que
moi ce qu'il va faire dans cette
émission monsieur qui changent rien que
vous 13 petits enfants sont à l'école
survient attendues vont alors voulez
vous nous expliquer ce que vous allez
faire dans l'émission et bien voilà
comme vous venez de le dire je vais
servir d'arbitré en même temps deux
poseurs de questions je crois que c'est
bien beau tout comme on a assez posé et
messieurs les concurrents écoutez bien
ce que je vais vous dire parce que vous
n'avez pas le droit de composer tous les
maux avec
les sept têtes qu'il sort va vous
désignez sont exclues parce que la
numération tous les noms propres de
toute nature les mots d'une lettre les
formes conjuguer des verbes sauf
toutefois l'infinitif et le participe
passé les onomatopées et les
interjections les préfixes et les
suffixes les signes comme relu ce
terrain les abréviations le tc et c'est
lé symbole chimique pour le cuivre cu et
je crois que quand j'aurai terminé cette
énumération je n'aurai plus qu'un mot à
ajouter pour vous encourager c'est que
je serai impitoyable pour les fautes
d'orthographe c'est très bien vous avez
compris monsieur bon eh bien je vous
rappelle que j'ai devant moi deux sabots
contenant d'un côté des voyelles et de
l'autre des consonnes que vous allez
pouvoir me demander dans l'ordre où ils
vous convient je vous rappelle les cieux
et je le dis surtout à l'adresse de nos
amis téléspectateurs vous avez 45
secondes pour demander vos lettres et
pour composer votre mot alors je vais
tirer au sort avec cette pièce pour
savoir celui d'entre vous qui aura
l'avantagé toutefois son état de
commencer
pile ou face est-ce que vous choisissez
face face c'est pile c'est pile alors
monsieur lichtenberg c'est à vous de
commencer la petite lumière est allumée
devant vous je demande le chronomètre
top c'est parti
une voix yeux une au genou et une
console est une consonne b une consonne
j'ai une foi yeux eux
32 25
quinze secondes
hop c'est terminé monsieur vous avez un
mot de combien de la double de l'être
seulement tout voulez-vous le composent
et me mais monsieur monsieur armand est
ce que vous faites mieux
trois lettres à mes une monsieur pichon
oui vous acceptez le monde mais bien un
fruit bien
et bien c'est donc monsieur armand qui
va prendre un bon départ en avançant de
3,15 à monsieur pichon est en train de
consulter son dictionnaire
ça va ça va dit il très vite tout le
monde est un petit peu ému messieurs
décontracté vous je vous en prie alors
bon nous acceptons le meut ce mot de
trois lettres
donc monsieur armand vous avancez 2 3
cases n'est ce pas vous allez de la case
1 à la case 3 mais voilà la case 3 est
une case noire et les cases noires ce
sont des cases dans lesquelles on ne
peut pas aller comme ça tout
tranquillement il faut pour y rester
subir un petit handicap et ce petit
handicap
c'est une question que va vous poser
monsieur pichon eh bien monsieur herman
je crois que vous avez de la chance vous
connaissez la marseillaise bon je ne
vous demanderai pas de la chanter et
simplement de répondre à la question
suivante voulez vous me dire les 4
premiers verres du couple et qui
commence par nous entrerons dans la
carrière ce couple est que l'on appelle
le couplet des enfants nous entrerons
dans la carrière qu'on nous ait ni n'y
seront plus nous y trouveront leur
poussière et la trace de leurs vertus
vous ne pouvez pas me donner notre
manque la trace tout ça
selon l'artiste yens les 15 secondes
sont écoulés car je signale que les
concurrents aux 15 secondes pour
répondre aux questions de toute façon je
pense monsieur blanchet une quelconque
pour la première question est pour un
mot je crois que c'est tout de même très
vite c'était l'exemple de leurs vertus
un exemple est la trace nous n'allons
pas être un moteur pour le début pour
l'aider d'accord facile à mais bon c'est
assez fou matthieu pichot ghilardi non
mais comme un bruit ça va vous êtes
d'accord rue
par conséquent monsieur armand
s'installe définitivement sur la case 3
bon eh bien monsieur armand c'est
toujours à vous de jouer puisque vous
avez pris le tour de monsieur
lichtenberg
vous avez utilisé trois lettres il en
reste quatre par conséquent ces quatre
lettres monsieur lichtenberg va devoir
les utiliser et je ne vais lui en
donnait que trois voyelles et consonnes
à son choix monsieur layton d'air à non
pardon peut-être monsieur en bon excusez
moi qu'on se console consomme fun on
aurait bien un âge qu'on sonne encore
une grosse s voyelles
y
vingt secondes
top gobbi busby un mot de quatre lettres
saleh à 2,5 mètres de sa lettre monsieur
richter vous faites mieux
non bien sûr alors c'est encore monsieur
armand qui va avancer de 5,4
ce qui l'amène à la case 8 la case 8
étant une case blanche c'est une case
100 questions qui par conséquent lui est
définitivement acquise je vous signale
amis téléspectateurs je vous signale au
passage que les ronds lumineux que vous
voyez sur le tableau qui se trouve à
l'intérieur du triangle sont pour
monsieur armand et que ce par conséquent
qui se trouve à l'extérieur marqueront
la vence de monsieur lichtenberg bien il
reste deux lettres
donc monsieur lichtenberg c'est à vous
de jouer et je vais vous en redonner
cinq autres voiliers le nom sonne quand
le men in ou à une console ray une
consonne j une voix yeux à 35 ans
je pense qu'en ce moment les
téléspectateurs cherche aussi à composer
un mot ce jeu est fait pour cela 10
secondes
top monsieur le mode coop l'autre c'est
déjà pas mal
je veux java en plus c'est un mot très
gai sur un air d'accordéon et monsieur
armand vous faites mieux non non alors
quatre cases pour monsieur lichtenberg